سلمى مشتعله على اكثر من محور وفي اكثر من
مكان حقيقه من اقصى شمال قطاع غزه حتى
المناطق الوسطى للقطاع حيث نستطيع ان نكشف
مخيمي البريج والنصيرات
هذان الميمان اللذان تعرض في الساعه
القليله الماضيه الى اكثر من غاره جويه
عنيفه استهدفت مناطق بعينها وكما نرى الان
عبر العدسه هنالك عده اماكن تتصاعد منها
اعمده خان في المناطق الشماليه تحديدا
لمدينه غزه حيث قال الجيش الاسرائيلي بانه
ينشط منذ ايام في حيي الدرج والزيتون
وواضح بان هنالك قصف مدفعي عنيف طال تلك
المناطق ايضا في الساعه الاخيره بالاضافه
الى غارات جويه اذا ما تعمقنا الى المناطق
الشماليه ايضا وفي طريقنا الى هنا الى هذه
المنطقه في غلاف غزه كانت ايضا المناطق
الشماليه في اقصى شمال قطاع غزه بيت حنون
وبيت لاهيا هي ايضا محاور اشتعال واشتباك
بما في ذلك مخيم جباليا وجباليا البلد
التي شاهدنا فيها اعمده الدخان تتصاعد من
اكثر من مكان واكثر من موقع كل هذا كان
ناجم عن غارات جويه وقصف مدفعي عنيف هذا
بالاضافه الى التفجيرات التي يقوم بها
الجيش الاسرائيلي في مواقع مختلفه في
محاوله لتفجير الانفاق الهجوميه في
الاماكن التي يصل اليها اذا هنالك تفجيرات
ايضا تجري على الارض وهنالك ايضا محاولات
لتجريف مناطق واسعه باكملها في المناطق
الشرقيه تحديدا لمدينه غزه في حي الشجاعيه
وفي احياء قريبه جدا من السياج الامني في
اطار ما تقوم به القوات الاسرائيليه في
تعميق او اقامه هذا ال هذه المنطقه
العازله لخلق عمق امني ما بين ما بين غلاف
غزه البلدات الاسرائيليه والمناطق
الفلسطينيه الماهوله نلاحظ حجم الدمار
الكبير في المناطق الشرقيه مئات المنازل
الاف الشقق السكنيه التي دمرت تدميرا
كاملا على نحو لم يعد بامكان الفلسطينيين
العوده اليها على الاطلاق وهذه هي المناطق
التي تحاول القوات الاسرائيليه انشاء
منطقه عازله فيها في اطار العمليات
العسكريه المتواصله في داخل قطاع غزه ومن
الواضح بان الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي كان
يمني النفس في ان يسيطر على المناطق
الشماليه اي بشكل كامل ونهائي قبل اسابيع
واضح بانه ما زال يشتبك حتى هذه الساعه مع
المقاومه الفلسطينيه التي تتصدى له في
اكثر من محور وفي اكثر من من مكان واذا ما
انتقلنا الى المناطق الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه
نحن نلاحظ ان منطقه جحر الديك ايضا تتعرض
لقصف مدفعي ولغات جويه بالاضافه الى كما
اشرت الى مخيمي البريج وصراط حيث نركز
الان عدسه الكاميرا هذه هي المناطق الوسطى
التي بدات فيها الفرقه او الفرقه 36 العمل
منذ ايام بحسب بيانات الجيش الاسرائيلي
كنا نسمع حتى في الساعات القليله الماضيه
اشتباكات بالاسلحه الرشاشه ايه الثقيله
وهذا يعني بان الاشتباكات ما زالت على
اشدها ووجها الى وجه في هذه المناطق
تحديدا واضح بان مخيمي ريج وان صرات منذ
ايام يشهدان غارات جويه عنيفه كان اخرها
فقط قبل دقائق معدوده على راس هذه النشره
وكذلك قصف مدفعي متقطع يشتد حينا ويخف
حينا اخر لكنه لا يتوقف لكن واضح بان
التركيز العسكري سلمى كما قال ايضا وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي يواف جلنت ليله امس بان
التركيز العسكري هو الان على منطقه
خانيونس وكما تعلمين فقد دفع الجيش
الاسرائيلي بسبعه الويه للمشاركه في هذا
في هذا النشاط العسكري كما يسمونه في تلك
المناطق ونحن نسمع الان الطائرات
العاموديه من نوع اباتشي التي عادت لتحوم
في اجواء هذه المنطقه وهذه المنطقه هي
مشتعله و ما زالت ما زال الحسم العسكري
فيها بعيد المنال عن الجيش الاسرائيلي
شكرا شكرا جزيلا لك من غلاف في غزه لياس
كرام مراسلنا كنت معنا من هناك